good morning i'm lieutenant ray spencer
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department
thank you all for coming out here this
morning to help us find the mother
who abandoned her newborn baby girl on
sunday afternoon
in an apartment complex near jones and
lake mead
before i get into the details i want to
recognize that this has been a very long
stressful year for all of us
and many have reached their breaking
point i tell you this because we are not
here to judge this mother
we are here to find her and check on her
well-being
on sunday afternoon there was a family
who was in an apartment
when they heard crying coming from
bushes
outside two of their children went
outside
to investigate the sounds that they had
heard
they went into the bushes and they found
a garbage bag and looked inside
and found a one day old baby girl with
the umbilical cord
still attached those children brought
the baby upstairs to their mother
who swaddled the baby and called 911.
we do not know who the mother is what we
do know is that the child is an
african-american
baby girl who was born within the 24
hours leading up to
being discovered i stress
during this conference that we have a
law in this state
to prevent this and that is the safe
haven law
anyone in this situation can drop
off a
any baby station medical facility
ambulance no questions asked
walk away the law prevents that anybody
follows them prevents from asking
further questions
and there's no repercussions the only
concern is the concern of that child
fortunately this baby girl is going to
be okay
in the situation because of these alert
people who
discovered her on sunday but i'm
pleading with you
to please stress this law
to anybody out there so this does not
have to happen again
the safe haven law is supposed to
prevent this
if anyone knows who the mother is that
delivered this baby
we suspect she lives in this in the
immediate vicinity
of lake mead and jones to reach out to
crime stoppers
you can do it anonymously that way we
can at least
locate her and check on her welfare to
make sure that she is also
not in a situation that's going to be
life-threatening
so with that i will take a couple
questions if you have them
right now we don't have a name
that we have we don't have a name
right now it's just the baby doe the
official name would be
lake mead and jones baby doe but we're
still trying to
find the mother and find that
information out
we think within a 30-minute window
potentially
of when the baby was put there around 12
o'clock sunday afternoon
and where she was born on sunday the
29th
there were very minor injuries scrapes
bruises type
injuries that were observed but as far
as it appears
that the baby is going to be long-term
no major ramifications from being left
outside
and that again is because of the
alertness of the family
who found the baby and took care of the
baby until medical personnel arrived
so once the baby is uh deemed medically
safe from the hospital
this baby will be placed in the care of
child protective services who will
house the child based upon their own
protocols which they have plenty of
foster
foster families that will take the baby
until
additional arrangements can be
we made checked the apartment complex
there is no video surveillance that we
have been able to locate at this point
we are in the process of still
canvassing with neighbors
from not just the apartment complex
where she was found but also
the entire vicinity we're putting a lot
of resources and a lot of effort to try
to find the mother
because we don't know the circumstances
that led her to
leave the baby where the baby was left
this is the first that i can tell you in
the recent months that we have had where
the child has been abandoned
and again i stress that we have a law
on the books for this where you can just
leave the baby
with personnel at a hospital and a fire
station to prevent this to make sure
that the baby is going to be safe
new mothers who are not planning on
being
mothers but for one reason or another
are now inside and
now this has happened do you think we're
going to see the kick and babies dropped
off
in that safe haven well again it's kind
of like i started this out
by stating we're all under a a lot of
stress the financial hardships the
stress of the pandemic
people are reaching their breaking point
and to prevent that that is why we call
you out here today to highlight this law
and it's a
it's an exceptional law that allows you
to drop off a baby
and face no repercussions no questions
you leave the baby with
trained personnel and the baby's going
to be safe
that is the important thing that we're
trying to make sure that if this happens
again
in a if a mother is in a situation where
she feels she cannot care for her
newborn baby
to bring that baby to a hospital to a
fire station so we're not out here
having this conference again
i'm not going to get into the potential
what ifs right now our main concern
right now is to find the mother
and make sure that she's going to be
okay
all right thank you guys appreciate it